super bowl 55 is just about here but
this year it's going to look a lot
different
as parties and large gatherings at bars
are really a thing of the past because
of the pandemic brian yeah tough to
throw a party these days not happening
madison kimbrough visiting two local
bars in town
to see how they are prepping for the big
game and what limitations they will have
in place
yes i'm live here at sky bar and grill
we are in the sky canyon area
right by smith's marketplace now take a
look behind me
where you can see i spoke to them in
another bar in
the southwest valley about covent 19
guidelines
in the midst of one of the biggest
sports days of the year
we're going to be at a 25 percent
capacity there is everything is done by
reservations only
we've taken a couple reservations but we
still have some available spots
and we'll be showing the game however
there'll be no super bowl party
this sunday will look a lot different
than years past as sports bars around
town
find ways to open their doors for the
big game in a safe way
the guests are participating well with
the coveted restrictions and
keeping their mask on and that's really
what we need is to make sure everybody
works together to ensure that everybody
stays safe
a day where people usually sit side by
side in large groups
right now the limit is four people per
table if your group is larger than that
you will be separated
we expect it to be a really good game
over at brook seas in the southwest
owner john brooks knows that a packed
house this year
is not an option for his bar we don't
have a lot going on this year because
we can't we're not trying to bring a
whole lot more people in we're gonna
we know we're gonna be turning people
away already which is very unfortunate
the maximum number of people in any
facility at this point is 50.
so we have to take reservations for
people overall both bars are just happy
to be able to serve the community with
masks social distancing
and paper menus in place
and again if you want to watch the big
game on sunday you must make a
reservation and both of these places
that we featured
do still have open slots so make sure
you call and again
make your reservation in advance
reporting live in sky canyon madison
kimbrough
8 news now